let's start with first just a general
sentiment check
how are you feeling about the bitcoin
market where we are coming into the end
of the year has anything changed
nothing's changed um i mean i think the
timeline is a little bit delayed like
compared to what a lot of people thought
in the fall at the beginning of q4 um
you know a lot of people were kind of
expecting to see to see higher prices
than than today and for you know
all-time highs to be excuse me for
all-time highs to continue to be to be
made here but in terms of the thesis in
terms of what bitcoin is and and you
know where we're going with this whole
thing nothing has changed i think you
know that's what we're going to dig into
a little bit today
all right so when we start looking at
some of the charts that we have here the
first that we're going to pull up is
this bitcoin store value medium of
exchange or unit of account and you just
have uh what looks like the price
pulled up in terms of uh
uh over the years what what exactly are
you showing here yeah so this is more of
just like a kind of a title slide i saw
some some of the jack discourse last
night um in the next slide it kind of it
was a question that says do you think
the that bitcoin will replace the us
dollar um and you know there's
definitely a lot of debate bitcoin is
digital gold or bitcoin is going to
displace a dollar or bitcoin uh to some
people is a ponzi scheme um but really i
think uh you know we're going to use
some some metrics today and look at some
charts and kind of break down what what
i believe and i think what a lot of
people
that are bitcoin proponents believe is
that bitcoin is actively becoming or is
already all three um and then the data
kind of shows that
all right so if we start with uh the
first chart we've got the issuance rate
and the circulating supply and market
cap all overlaid on each other what
exactly is this showing
yeah so this is kind of supporting the
store value argument right so you hear a
lot of people um increasingly over the
last couple years this has been an
accepted kind of proposition bitcoin is
digital gold it's a digital store of
value
and while that was controversial for a
long time
a lot of the skeptics um you know
besides a few have come to accept that
you know bitcoin is a store of value and
you know in the 21st century um
especially after the kind of covid
madness and all the trillions of dollars
of stimulus bitcoin is a store of value
and so you know it's the one thing we
know that it has a hard cap is
absolutely scarce in the world
this issuance rate or inflation rate um
is programmatically trending to towards
zero over time uh the blue line that's
actually in log scale so uh in linear
and linear scale it looks like the
issuance rate is already basically at
zero
um and the market uh the market cap is
really just a testament of people around
the world allocating you know resources
and capital to this asset class because
of its monetary assurances and so the
store value argument is stronger than
ever but you know i don't think it stops
there and that's when uh you know the
discourse gets a little more interesting
got it and so really what this is
showing is as that issuance rate goes
down or some people could think that it
almost has like an inflation rate uh the
circulating supply goes up right uh
because we're getting more and more
bitcoins just at a slower pace uh but
the market cap has continued to grow at
the exact same time as well which ends
up being uh kind of a what you would
expect if you've got a finite supply
asset with a disinflationary monetary
supply schedule uh and increasing demand
is you're going to continue to get the
price to go up even though there's a
little bit of bitcoin still coming into
the market uh the demand outpaces that
and that's where you get market cap
growth right
yeah exactly i mean it's pretty simple
it's how many dollars are going to exist
in 2030 or in 2100 right no one knows no
one knows really for any other asset
except bitcoin and and you know this
because you can run a full node on you
know an old laptop or you can verify the
supply on your smartphone and there's no
other technology yes there are other
crypto assets that are somewhat
transparent but the thing is that none
of the monetary policies of these other
assets or you know digital uh assets are
basically as uh tried and tested as
bitcoin and no one can change bitcoin um
and every protocol change that has
occurred has been um opt-in voluntary
it's a soft fork um there's there's no
hard forks or changes to the monetary
policy of bitcoin you know whereas other
crypto protocols or assets um or
currencies if you want to call them that
have have done that plenty of time so in
terms of in terms of absolute scarcity
nothing in the world um has or can
compete with bitcoin
the next thing we've got is the hash
rate 7dx since 2017 which is the bonkers
number uh
explain why you think this is so
important
yeah so this is kind of um on the store
value side of things as well 70x in the
last five years i'm just kind of
understanding what that means what hash
rate actually means you can you know for
for people that are more kind of visual
and don't really understand what bitcoin
mining is
think of the you know gold miners going
in with with shovels and excavators and
digging into the earth to find this
monetary asset well think about if if
that had increased
70 fold over the last five years just
the amount of expenditure and the amount
of resources that are going into
actually extracting you know that that
shiny rock out of the earth well bitcoin
is that but in the digital form and it's
doing it all over the world um with
sometimes nothing other than just a
satellite signal and a wasted energy
source um where there is no economic
value
and it's basically securing and being
rewarded uh it's securing the most
powerful computer network in the world
it's being it's they're being rewarded
with the only absolutely scarce monetary
asset and so incentives are aligned
that's all bitcoin is just economic
incentives it's completely voluntary
it's opt-in
and hash rate continues to grow at a
just mind-boggling exponential pace
when we think about uh the entire
network hash rate in 2013 that is
equivalent to one s19j pro is that true
yeah so the s19 jpro it's top of the
line uh you know new asic um but that
basically spins off 110 tara hash a day
i think it costs around fifteen thousand
dollars maybe twenty thousand it's it's
extremely hard to get miners with all
the kind of supply chains backed up and
they're back ordered from you know
months or years but yeah one asic one
one new top-of-the-line asic is
equivalent to the entire network hash
rate of 2013. um and so it just kind of
shows you
moore's laws in play there with kind of
semiconductors becoming more and more
efficient but that just shows you just
like the just absolutely insane growth
and just amount of a physical capital um
and resources you know backing this
network uh there is definitely a
tangible aspect to it despite it being
you know
thin air or you know
what a lot of people like to call it
yeah it's pretty incredible uh when we
look at the next chart we've got bitcoin
is on pace to settle 45 trillion in 2021
totaling twice as much value as all of
his previous years combined
that is an insane number
yeah so this is a chart from you seeing
that at arc they put out great stuff
um and this is just kind of this is
going into more of the medium of
exchange aspect of it right so everyone
gets store value you can buy bitcoin you
can you can leave it on coinbase or you
can send it to your cold storage and you
can sit there and watch it and and it's
a pretty strong bet over time that it'll
increase your purchasing power um just
due to the absolute scarcity of it and
due to the adoption curve and more and
more people coming to this asset class
because of those properties right
but most people um or you know less than
the amount of people that understand the
story value side don't really you know
the the medium of exchange or maybe the
settlement aspect of bitcoin is very
underappreciated so this network in a
completely apolitical sovereign way
where there's there's no ceo there's no
board there's no uh there's really
there's no off switch right china just
picked up and you know 50 of the network
was forced to to shut off overnight uh
and bitcoin kept on chugging right so
you know 45 trillion dollars or on pace
for that in 2021
um it's a pretty insane number and so uh
you know you're you're doubling or i'm
sorry yeah doubling visa i believe uh
and and that's you know
pretty different when you're looking at
settlement assurances but say the best
comparison is fed wire well that's you
know we're already six percent of the
way there compared to fedwire and so i
wouldn't bet on this trend uh stopping
anytime soon uh and you know that kind
of supports the more medium of exchange
aspect to it there's you know final
settlement all over the world 24 7 365.
yeah it's pretty incredible uh bitcoin
the cumulative network transfer volume
22.2 uh
22.6 trillion as of 1221. uh which is uh
today
yeah so that's the first chart show just
total volume in this one um i should
have labeled it a little better shows
change adjusted transfer volume so the
bitcoin utxo set when say you have one
bitcoin and you send point five
well i send point five to you pomp and
point five bitcoin goes back to me and
that's a that's a change that's uh you'd
like change for the utx though and so
technically change adjusted volume just
filters out that 0.5 bitcoin i sent back
to to myself um just that's how bitcoin
transactions work um and so over the
course of its history um bitcoin is has
done 22.6 trillion dollars of change
adjusted volume um and that's you know
obviously hockey sticking up and to the
right and so i just kind of shows you
that you know this protocol is
continuing to grow and in terms of
medium exchange it's a lot bigger and
does a lot more volume than people think
which means that bitcoin in 2021 has
done over 10 trillion right so you know
about 10 to 12 trillion of this about
half of it was done this year in 2021
compared to what it's done since its
beginning of its life
yep correct it's pretty insane yeah
absolutely nuts and and uh i don't know
the exact visa uh settlement number but
i do believe that uh visa's annual
transaction volume
is now
right around what bitcoins is like
they're they're much closer than you
would think right i think that visa if i
remember correctly is somewhere in the
like 14 to 16 uh
trillion number and obviously bitcoin
being at let's call it 12 or so uh
hasn't quite eclipsed it yet but uh but
we're getting pretty damn close
yeah and i think a lot of people it
should be to be said that you know
comparing visa to bitcoin it's
definitely um a cool kind of comparison
and a milestone but just in terms of
settlement assurances and final and you
know just
yeah settlement finality um it's it's a
lot different right swiping my car to
visa basically they have an internal
ledger and they just they just debit
someone and basically just change the
ledger a little bit but it can be
changed uh pretty easily there's there's
no final settlement for sometimes you
know weeks or months on end and at the
end of at the end of whatever period
that is the bank and and visa will you
know transfer over you know billions of
dollars and kind of that's the final
settlement but when people are comparing
you say a 10 minute bitcoin transaction
or bitcoin blocks to visa it's
definitely the wrong comparison and i
think that next this next chart that
we'll show
is more apples to apples
all right now we've got the lightning
network public channel capacity
yeah so this is in usd uh and it's in
logarithmic scale so uh the growth is a
lot more impressive if you're looking at
it in linear terms but this is public
channel lightning network capacity so
back in 2017 back when there was the
scaling wars um bitcoin can't scale was
the narrative um the the solutions were
bitcoin cash or other altcoins um the
payments narrative despite not being
done today was was pretty big back then
and there's a lot of questions about how
could bitcoin ever be this you know as
some proponents would say world reserve
currency if if it could only do you know
seven transactions per second which is
completely the wrong way to look at it
um so here comes the lightning network
um and with the segwit soft fork in 2017
um there was some upgrades that could
allow for light the lightning network to
be built which was just a concept
conceived in 2016. um so since then um
you basically have um
this lightning network which is just an
application layer or a software layer
above the bitcoin network and it's
completely it's completely open source
it's completely opt-in and and basically
it allows for bitcoin payments to occur
somewhat instantaneously and for
basically no cost or little to no cost
and so we've seen that that growth is is
exponential and you're seeing a lot of
companies like strike and open node and
companies all over the world just
basically opt into this um open for
basically not free but uh you know
voluntary settlement layer uh on top of
bitcoin and so this allows for micro
payments this allows i can send you one
satoshi pop and so that's something that
was never possible with with bitcoin on
the base layer um and it's just this is
basically how bitcoin will scale to
billions and billions of people and it's
it's not uh appreciated nearly enough
completely agree bitcoin price drawdown
from all-time high when you see this all
of a sudden maybe uh maybe we shouldn't
be complaining so much because uh there
are some epic epic drawdowns over the
years but uh what is this showing
yeah so we we covered store value we
covered medium of exchange
what's the last one unit of account um
so how could bitcoin ever be a unit of
account if it's if it's this volatile um
so
obviously we're looking at a logarithmic
scale of bitcoin in the background there
and the red is showing the drawdowns
from all time high
so really kind of what this is pointing
at is you know the volatility is the
price you pay for returns and when when
something is growing in exponential
fashion um you will see uh very standard
double digit uh you know 20 30 40 50
drawdowns along the way um and that's
just basically more opportunity to
accumulate
and to you know just to get your hands
on this pristine absolutely scarce asset
so currently you know 31 down from
all-time highs uh for anyone that's been
in bitcoin for more than a couple months
even it's it's really nothing
and it's an opportunity to just continue
to stack so you know just some context
and and the next few charts here will
break down why bitcoin as a unit of
account is uh quite superior
all right now we've got s p 500
uh
as just the first chart uh let's just do
the uh the actual price chart itself
so stocks only go up right or at least
that's what facts uh
that's what uh has you know we've been
taught over the last 24 months or so but
why is that um and a lot of people think
they're getting rich just you know
especially asset holders um you know
that everything's going up and to the
right but in reality uh it's more of a
farce and or maybe a focade and actually
it's just the money is debasing so what
happens if we standardize s p 500 and we
put it in m2 money supply terms uh it
looks a lot different and so what we're
looking at since 2020 uh if you just if
you just standardize uh this chart in
terms of m2 money stock the s p 500 is
basically flat um and so a lot of people
that think they've gotten pretty rich
over the last 18 24 months
in reality it's just a function of
monetary expansion um and so this kind
of um leads you to believe that the
dollar um over the short term while
i guess the fed or other you know kind
of public officials would call it stable
um it's actually a melting ice cube as
some would like to say and and if you're
valuing anything uh whether it's assets
goods services you know home prices
anything uh in big and in dollar terms
uh you're gonna you're gonna it's gonna
kind of skew you to believe that things
are getting more expensive when in
reality
many things are getting less expensive
it's just the currency the unit is
devaluing um and so here we have a
solution which is bitcoin
got it and so when you divide it by this
m2 doesn't look so hot and my guess is
that if you actually went ahead and you
denominated this in bitcoin obviously it
would be down significantly uh which i
think is uh you're oh yeah it is your
next one of course you're two steps
ahead of me go ahead yeah it's like
little bread crumbs right like you're
just this is like a little game go ahead
yeah so i mean volatility obviously is
there you see in march of 2020 that that
big green candle but over the long term
um bitcoin is the best unit of account
you can use um nothing else is
absolutely scarce like we've kind of
covered and so uh just denominating
something as simple as s p or even
individual stocks uh in bitcoin terms
will lead you to be one of the best uh
or most ahead of the game capital
allocators out there i think this is
kind of the strategy for savvy investors
over the next decade and it has been in
the last decade but increasingly i think
it will become the standard as
denominating your returns against
bitcoin all right and then lastly you've
got micro strategy both against dollars
and bitcoin how are we looking
yeah so um talking about going on a
bitcoin standard valuing your your
company valuing you know your assets and
bitcoin terms here's microstrategy since
uh they've adopted a bitcoin standard up
282 percent um obviously some pretty
spectacular growth uh
for a company that was was kind of
treading water for the last decade and
now if we denominate in bitcoin terms um
they're doing fantastic and they have
110 000 bitcoin um but their unit their
their share price in satoshis their
share price uh you know in bitcoin terms
has basically surprisingly or maybe not
surprisingly been flat right so so they
have actually kept pace with the bitcoin
standard um and so few companies can say
the same um and i think this will become
kind of the way that you know uh savvy
investors and increasingly everybody
will have to value things uh in the 21st
century uh bitcoin is the most superior
unit of account uh and if you're valuing
things bitcoin yes there's there's
short-term volatility but over the long
term uh you're definitely ahead of the
game and you'll you'll get a step on on
people who are not
how do you think about uh
bitcoin
when it starts to become less volatile
so obviously everything is kind of
crashing against bitcoin because
bitcoin's price is going up at a pretty
insane uh rate compared to us dollars if
bitcoin is to eventually reach
price stability in u.s dollar terms
which
may or may not happen but if that was to
occur how do you think about it then
being denominated all these other assets
yeah so i think if you look at a lot of
things there's a pretty fantastic chart
out there that i don't have on me at the
moment but it's over the last 20 years
the price of everything um
from like technology to education to
health care to consumer goods and yeah
you know the university education and
basically everything that technology has
touched is is way down at the price of
the the price of a tv or a semiconductor
or just an iphone think about how much
an iphone gives you over the last 10
years well maybe the price has gone up
but the value is gone way way up so
actually technology um it's it's
deflationary in the sense that you get
more for less
and so when you when you don't have that
expanding you know
monetary unit the dollar expanding money
supply that's chasing
everything that's becoming more
expensive over the last decade or two um
it's because more dollars are chasing
that university education subsidized
healthcare subsidized all of these
things that are becoming way way more
expensive is because
essentially the government or you know
just the economy in general is chasing
an increasing amount of
throwing an increasing amount of dollars
at it and so that's why you see these
things becoming exponentially more
expensive over time
i i believe on a bitcoin standard on an
absolutely scarce monetary standard
global monetary standard uh things will
gradually uh decrease in in price over
time as the as the money approves value
basically as the world becomes more
productive uh your money accrues value
uh in everything else and so i think
that's what you know what the future
holds and it won't you won't see these
exponential gains that we see uh over
the last decade and i think over the
coming decade but uh you know i think
you would expect with human productivity
your purchasing power would increase one
to two to maybe five percent a year
depending uh on a bitcoin standard and i
think that's you know that's pretty
exciting
when you start to think about um
how well people understand this like
what's your take on the jack dorsey web
three tweets versus uh uh kind of the
web three pro argument if you will like
what do you think
yeah i think um i i kind of agree with
jack here in the sense that i'm all for
the free market and i'm all for you know
people going and building things and
trying things out a hundred percent um
but i think a lot of uh the incentives
are skewed in a lot of these if you want
to call it web3
applications or ecosystems whether it's
you know with and and not that you know
investing is bad in general right you
know the argument for pre mine is well
every stock or company is pre-mined um
and that's fair but uh you know if we're
talking about a company or a security
versus an open protocol i think it's a
lot you know a little bit different or
actually a lot different and so you know
bitcoin crypto kind of gets all lumped
into one uh and i think it's it's quite
different uh we covered it a little bit
last week the differences between say
bitcoin and ethereum
uh and i'm fine i'm all for the free
market i don't want regulators to come
in and clamp down on on these builders
or engineers um at all but i think just
in terms of
say an open internet and uh you know
so-called decentralization um a lot of
it's more decentralization theater and
that's fine i think just there's quite a
difference between say bitcoin uh versus
what a lot of these other tokens
protocols um web3 applications are doing
and that's fine right um but just you
know saying everything is going to be on
a blockchain or creator economy and
everyone's going to have their own
personal token um i mean it's ambitious
and so we'll see what happens but you
know i think the biggest kind of idea in
the room uh is you know what jack thinks
and that's sound money for the world i
think that's that's the big idea here
john what questions you got yeah dylan
thanks for joining us um
so how have you thought about the hash
rate is this kind of it's up what
seventy percent since 2017 what do you
think it looks like moving forward
yeah um 70x since since 2017. i think
and i think it continues to just kind of
bend up and to the right it's it's hard
to see that that sort of exponential
growth um as as we kind of get closer
and closer to um
not the end of moore's law but as
moore's law kind of slows down a little
bit um i'm not i'm not calling an end to
the the efficiency of semiconductors and
computing power but um you you've
started to see somewhat of a commod
commodification of the of asics of
bitcoin miners um an s9 has been around
for you know i think four or five years
and it's still spitting off a lot of a
lot of free cash flow a lot of profit um
and so you know i think the new miners
today you'll be able to plug in for for
quite a long time and for them to to be
quite profitable um you know whereas say
the mining rigs or you know the usb
sticks that you could plug into your
laptop from 2012 aren't going to be
profitable anymore you can't mine
bitcoin with gpus and be profitable but
i think a lot of these asics will be
around for a long time uh despite the
fact that bitcoin hashrate i would i
would think is gonna probably ten uh or
a hundred x over the coming decade um
just with you know the pure amount of
incentives that that will exist for for
people to you know plug these machines
in i think every energy producer is
gonna get involved um and in a big way
but uh we're just starting to see that
play out how do you think about the
consumer like the retail consumer
getting involved in mining
versus
guys
it's pretty exciting i think
we're gonna see i i believe we're gonna
see especially in cold um cold regions
or climates um you know the rise of the
home miner um you know some very very
savvy kind of engineers or bitcoiners if
you want to say i've been doing this
already but the reality is you know
these these miners kick off a lot of
excess heat um and so doing it uh
somewhere that's pretty cold is actually
you know you can kind of get a two for
one where you're you're mining bitcoin
and you're producing a lot of excess
energy and heat and that byproduct can
actually you know heat your home so it's
like almost two birds with one stone and
so um it's something that actually i'm i
am exploring currently uh but i think
we'll see that a lot and it'll kind of
just become i think square's working on
that right they're working on building
that out and in their uh in their app as
well as um working on an asic so um that
would be pretty exciting and i think uh
we're a little bit away from kind of
that that becoming the standard but it
would be awesome to see uh in you know
coming five years or so i agree
what i also think would be really
interesting i don't think i've seen one
yet that seems viable and commercial
is when you start to get uh anything
that plugs into uh some sort of
electricity and it mines bitcoin in its
off hours so like i'll use the super
egregious
almost absurd example but like you could
see it happening
is somebody builds like a microwave when
it's plugged in
uh it's pulling a little bit of power
right because i was obviously able to
display the time and that type of stuff
but is there a world where the microwave
pays for itself by being able to mine
bitcoin even though it's got very little
computing power right so like that's the
agrees example like okay now walk it
back into well what happens if all of a
sudden you're able to take other things
like the tesla power wall may be a good
example right if they were essentially
able to say hey look we're going to use
renewable power that's stored in this
battery and we're going to take that and
then build kind of a mining component to
it you can actually hey when you're not
consuming the power if you don't uh if
you're running out or
of capacity or something just go ahead
and almost like burn it but you're
burning it by using it to drive some
sort of monetary value and help secure
the decentralized bitcoin network like i
think go ahead
it's pretty interesting i think bitcoin
mining kind of will will you know almost
like flatten out these um these
disparities and energy prices across the
world right you're seeing um you know
you're seeing a huge energy crisis in
europe right so uh bitcoin miners in
europe currently um they're they're
probably not going to be um on full tilt
right they're gonna they're gonna
instead sell their their energy to the
grid right you're seeing a lot of like
you know grid miners that um like in
texas per se um that are that are
establishing this base load uh energy
demand and then when demand spikes they
turn off and so you can see that kind of
at a micro level right or say maybe not
a microwave but say a water heater right
so um a lot of these things are you know
continuing to
be built out and there's engineers all
over the world kind of working on this
stuff um bitcoin mining uh with
immersion cooling right it's kind of
like these these ideas that are coming
out of nowhere um and they're you know
they're really fascinating and i i mean
we're just scratching the surface in
terms of what can be done uh with kind
of this this new found um demand or
ability to take energy from anywhere uh
and and turn it into sound money and so
i think the applications and the the you
know the engineering uh you know feats
that will be built on top of this and
around this network uh is something that
i i can't fathom and i'll let other
people figure that out
last question i have for you is going
into uh christmas you got any advice for
folks in terms of how they can help
orange peel their family
that's a good question um yeah i mean i
would just say uh everyone it you know
it takes time and everyone will kind of
come to bitcoin when they're ready but
just planting the seed about uh what
sound money and a low time preference
does uh is is important um kind of just
you know distincting bitcoin from a lot
of you know speculative investments and
even bitcoin itself on a shorter time
frame is speculative right so maybe
showing the the four year dca returns um
which i don't know off the top of my
head but i know they're they're pretty
strong and just kind of preaching a
little time preference maybe saying why
is everything getting more expensive in
the world uh whether it's housing or
food or energy or anything else right uh
and and
kind of establishing that it's not a
result of greedy corporations as maybe
an elizabeth warren would say but it's
more so about an expanding money supply
and just kind of planting the seed
because
ultimately everybody will will need
bitcoin everybody will own bitcoin uh
and that may sound controversial today
but i think 10 years from now it won't
be at all and so just kind of you know
planting a seed with people that you
care about is is uh you know definitely
a good gift to give at least uh for
their future self
i i think that's a great way to uh to
end it uh if we do a quick follower
check
98.8 man we're about to cross 100k
this is i think well i think we were
talking what you were at 50k a couple of
weeks ago
yeah i think the first time i came on i
was i was a little bit under that and so
definitely
definitely uh getting close there making
moves john
yeah where you at i'm at right under 60
and dylan i just congratulations
when you
when you provide good content though
people um
people go to it so appreciate success
that's how the world works all right i'm
gonna drop uh drop his twitter account
in here uh if you're not following dylan
get with the program let's go
gotta we got things we gotta get done so
dylan thank you so much for uh for doing
this have a uh a merry christmas happy
holidays whatever the appropriate thing
to say these days is uh just enjoy the
time with your family um and then uh
i guess well next tuesday is the next
show that we'll do so dylan will be back
the next time that you guys see us
you'll see dylan which will be uh be
pretty good
great happy holidays guys thanks for
having me on all right buddy sounds good
thank you